Film Courage: We’re hoping you can give
us a brief profile of how you found distribution
for each of your films, from OUTSIDE SALES,
WEATHER GIRL, 6 MONTH RULE and now with CUT
TO THE CHASE?
Blayne Weaver: Sure.
OUTSIDE SALES, we didn’t know what the hell
we were doing.
That’s a very important thing about my first
movie.
I was doing well acting-wise and like this
was the movie that I sold my house to finance.
I had done this cartoon for Disney where I
do the voice of Peter Pan and I made a good
amount of money and I bought a house.
And then I sold the house to finance my first
movie.
We made the film and traveled all over the
film festival circuit and spent all this money.
And then came out the other side and was like
“I’m broke.”
I don’t have distribution for the movie
and what do I do?
So that one [OUTSIDE SALES] was crazy.
It took about a year of just like talking
to everybody and finally we landed with this
company and got a DVD deal.
Which again, this was when the system wasn’t
working very well.
So it’s like we got a DVD deal.
No money up front but they threw us a big
release party and that was pretty much it.
But the movie was out.
That was an important thing.
WEATHER GIRL was a way better experience.
WEATHER GIRL got into the Slamdance film festival.
We had some cool actors.
We had Mark Harmon, Kaitlin Olson, Tricia
O’Kelley (who was on The New Adventures
of Old Christine) and they all came out to
Park City [Utah] with us.
That helped promote the movie and got a distribution
deal right there and we sold to Lifetime [Movie
Network] which was really where the money
came in so that paid back all of our investors
and then we had this huge international deal
where they never paid us.
So we had to sue this company in order to
get them to settle for 1/5th of what they
owed us.
Again, the system just didn’t work.
It was the kind of thing where people…the
distributors…not all of them but a lot of
them would just refuse to pay until you sued
them because they knew you didn’t have any
money.
So if you sued them and got that far, then
they would settle for like 1/5th for what
they owe you.
Which is a lot of the…politically this kind
of business is being talked about a lot right
now and in my experience, it happens all the
time.
Like the little guy, screaming and yelling
about “Where is the money that you owe me?”
and them saying “No, no, now.
Alright, here!
I’ll pay you 1/5th and you’ll be happy
to have it.”
Luckily that is happening less now with distributors.
But that was WEATHER GIRL.
So with WEATHER GIRL we made all of our money
back, but before we got into profit, we had
this problem with our international distributor.
[With our movie] 6 MONTH RULE we premiered
at the Austin [Texas] Film Festival.
Film Buff came to us.
Film Buff is Cinetic Media’s kind of little
brother in the indie film world and they put
us out on iTunes VOD and like that.
It was a great experience.
We’re still out there with Film Buff.
6 MONTH RULE, check it out!
[My new movie] CUT TO THE CHASE, we finished
the film and we’ve just been traveling film
festival wise and like having conversations
and we met with 108 Media Corp.
They seem down with the movie and we certainly
speak the same language and they’re bringing
us out March 7th [2017]!
So I’m excited!
Question for the Viewers: Have you distributed
a movie?
Share a story or something you’ve learned
from the process below on this Youtube video.